I'm dr.
András
surgeon candidate
health education content manufacturer
As a health care worker for many years
experience deteriorating conditions
migration
the lack of tools
professional standards
my girlfriend is already working abroad for a significant part
assuming that too
to reimburse their full vocational training costs
as to stay at home
not the money
or moved abroad for the hope of easy success
but because they feel
that in the circumstances at home
they can't meet for medical weddings
unable to properly care for patients
I thought about it several times
to follow their example
but the love of country and the will to keep at home
even though I saw it
that everything is getting worse and worse
but I had to see
that the point has come
when there is nowhere to back down
there is nothing to wait for
me too
I have to do it for my country and for domestic health
I think all Hungarian people have a right
for the right level of health care
and for all healthcare workers
especially for professionals
has the right to professional and financial appreciation
the situation of Hungarian health care for all Hungarian people
touched and showed us
that we can only improve care
How to Face Problems
we compare the data even then
how if very serious errors are revealed
because this is the only way we can fix these errors
I want to
to talk about the problems in Hungary and
regardless of the political side
we can do it together
to make domestic healthcare better
the competence of the Member States of health
belongs to the European Union
but the union is very much
Member States may contribute to the health
to support its system
in this seven-year cypress,
twelve times the amount
more than five billion
Euro is available to support healthy programmes
Hungary is still one of the smallest
shows activity
in the utilization of these amounts
Attracting
with the confidence in me I wish with humility
at the same time it is irresistible
to represent the Hungarian people
and the interests of the Hungarian people in the European Union